art is an elusive specter it can be
harder to catch than scp-682
harder to explain than scp-055
and have as profound effects on our
minds as scp-035
it exists in our hearts and our brains
it's something we can both discover and
impose paintings sculptures performance
music film photography animation game
design and so much more exists under its
umbrella thomas merton once said art
enables us to find ourselves and lose
ourselves at the same time and we here
at scp explained are inclined to agree
even the video you're watching right now
is a kind of art it's the product of
hard work by writers editors animators a
voice artist hello and the producers who
bring it all together really where would
we be without it but of course there's
always going to be people out there who
want to push the boundaries of art just
that little bit further the avant-garde
artists who work on the fringes pioneers
willing to delve further into the
darkest corners of human experience and
sometimes even beyond that's right
welcome to the wonderful and weird world
of an artists a word that in and of
itself has a kind of artistry to it it's
short for anomalous artists as in
artists who work with the medium of
explicitly anomalous objects or
materials the more perceptive among you
may have also noticed its similarity to
the word anarchists as in rejecters of
rigid rules and order like the kind
imposed by the scp foundation and when
it comes to the world of n artists
you'll find that a certain group comes
up again and again and again are we cool
yet you've probably heard of it before
in passing but there's a lot about this
anomalous art collective that remains
mysterious until today we're going to
grab our berets and paint stained aprons
and dive deep into the anart scene as
well as their most controversial group
of interest one thing is for sure it's
going to get incredibly incredibly
strange from here on in but hey it's art
what can you expect the structure and
reputation of are we cool yet is a
complicated and contentious topic even
within the world of an art much like the
serpent's hand the group is incredibly
decentralized with no governing body or
binding ethos save for the commitment to
produce an art proponents of are we cool
yet think of it as a kind of binding
ethos someone can become a member of our
week cool yet without even knowing about
the group beforehand this is why as long
as the memory and reputation of the
group remains alive the scp foundation
can't effectively shut them down some
work under the banner of are we cool yet
alone toiling away driven by sheer
passion for the art they create others
work in creative salons typically led by
a smaller group of artistic visionaries
working to turn their combined skills
into more ambitious varieties of anart a
common philosophy of the group is
wanting to make their art visible to the
world often to make a statement or start
a discussion among the public naturally
this particular drive is liable to make
local foundation authorities burst a
blood vessel or maybe they really just
don't get art i mean look at dr gears
especially does he strike you as the
kind of guy who would take some time out
of his day to stroll around a gallery
he'd probably murmur some snide comment
about it being a waste of printing paper
anyway before we proceed further into
are we cool yet as it is today its
relationship with other groups of
interest its splinter cells and some of
its notable creations its members have
produced we need to go back to the past
and discuss the group's creation
thankfully this group's history can be
traced back to the 1800s rather than us
needing to trace it all the way back to
the creation of humanity and the
universe like the church of the broken
god or the children of the scarlet king
the rather amazing thing about this
particular group is that its whole
identity can be traced back to an
argument between two famous artists
marcel duchamp and ruiz marcos for those
who need a little refresher on art
history duchamp's most famous pieces are
probably fountain the iconic signed
urinal an lhooq
the painting of the mona lisa defaced
with a mustache and a goatee and ruiz
marcos is best known for painting the
colors in your darkest nightmares that
strange feeling you get at an empty
train station in the middle of the night
and the subtle whiff of burnt toast you
get before a cerebral event the
following is a critical extract from the
coolest war memories of a critic an
anonymously penned opus on the nature of
anart and the creation of are we cool
yet detailing the group's early history
and defining embryonic moments in the
19th century the march of progress made
it possible for the first time for human
science to contemplate and comprehend
those phenomenon which had long seemed
to contravene the laws of nature within
a matter of decades concepts that had
long been viewed as witchcraft or
sorcery were laid bare in the terms of a
new and secret science and governments
and organizations around the world began
to classify study and collect all such
anomalies and just as artists throughout
history have turned a critical eye to
the events of the day in their work so
too did the artists of this scientific
renaissance begin to interpret these new
discoveries on canvas by the 1870s paris
was the center of the world of anomalous
art and the city stood witness to
endless debates about the role of the
anomalous in art or whether such a role
existed at all when in 1874 the famous
salon des magnifiques refused to allow
any works of a phantasmagorical nature
to be displayed at the grand exhibition
those artists shut out by the committee
organized their own counter-exhibition
to be held at the same time across the
river sol neu de vinu magnifique as the
show came to be called was the talk of
the parisian press for months earning
equal amounts of curiosity dismal and
outright derision but the exiled
gadflies had made their point the
paranormal the anomalous and the bizarre
had found a place in the world of art
and would not be so easily gotten rid of
some new de venus magnifique held its
exhibitions every 10 years thereafter
and as time passed the world of
anomalous art grew larger from its
beginnings in paris artists from all
across france and europe and later from
the americas and the orient as well
began attending the increasingly
prestigious and increasingly bizarre and
difficult to keep hidden from the
disdainful eyes of a concerned
government exhibition expressing new and
different interpretations of the role of
the anomalous in human life it was at
the sixth decennial exhibition in 1924
that the growing rift between the two
largest schools of thought logical
versus emotional science versus faith
old world versus new came to a head but
it was at that show that for the first
time the works of the french surrealist
marcel duchamp would be exhibited
alongside those of ruiz marcos the
mexican artist whose themes of magical
realism and religious are intertwined
with the viscerally accessible for
tenure of our world headset art critics
worldwide at war with each other those
who saw the two during the days leading
up to the openings of the exhibition
said they spent nearly the entire time
in heated discussion with one another in
english for neither spoke the other's
mother tongue confidently about
everything under the sun the importance
of the artist in relation to his work
the importance of context faith
knowledge love free will god the state
democracy marxism the war the league of
nations and the best way to serve a cup
of coffee it seemed that they might
continue bickering through the entire
exhibition but as the artist prepared to
greet the assembled press on the morning
of its grand opening they appear to have
eventually come to an understanding if
there is one image that comes to mind of
any art historian when the 1924 expo is
brought up it is of that iconic photo of
duchamp and ruiz posing side by side
with their fellow artists in front of
the still closed doors marcos seemingly
leaning over to whisper something in
dushan's ear for decades many have
speculated on what words marcos had for
his colleague during that memorable
instant a question of metaphysics or a
challenge an affirmation of their coming
to terms a reminder of the reason why
they were there at that moment of time
perhaps as an expression of amazement at
the multitudes that had come to see them
according to one reporter who claimed he
stood close enough to overhear that
whisper admits the din of the crowd it
was all five at once expressed in four
simple words are we cool yet as you can
see the themes that run through the
entirety of this group of interest got
their start early on the leading ones
are conflict and the desire to prove
oneself being excluded from the
prestigious 19th century french art
salon salondes magnifique led to them
creating their iconic gathering and
exhibition some new devenu magnifique
which translates loosely to have we
become magnificent an ironic jab about
gatekeeping in the art world to have
one's anarch featured at some new de
venue magnifique held only once every 10
years is the greatest honor for any
artist that is a devotee of are we cool
yet and their practices however
something that is extremely important to
note is that this doesn't necessarily
apply to all antartists out there after
all and artists like all creative
spirits have a tendency to be highly
individualistic and some have bones to
pick with the way that are we cool yet
operates one notable splinter group
broke away in 2013 to form a far smaller
group of interests known as gamers
against weed the gamers didn't exactly
jive with the fact that some of the
anarch made by the members of are we
cool yet hurt people specifically the
founder of gamers against weed jude
creont lost a friend to a dangerous
piece of anart at an are we cool yet
exhibition the gamers also just found
that are we cool yet had a weirdly
intense energy that seriously harshened
their vibe and as a result they went
their own direction to perform more
harmless and goofy anomalous pranks like
creating
scp-3108 the nerfing gun and
scp-2586 mr literal serial killer and we
swear that's less nasty than it sounds
the violence that this particular art
collective allows is a point of
contention among a lot of n artists some
ex-members have joined the more
pacifistic sex of the serpent's hand
where they can still follow their dreams
of exposing the anomalous to the public
without needing to rub elbows with the
kind of people who believe that art
projects have a certain amount of
acceptable casualties naturally because
of their lies a fair attitude towards
death and destruction as well as their
commitment to making sure their unique
anarch is seen by the world are we cool
yet is actively despised by the scp
foundation the global occult coalition
the fbi's unusual incidence unit and the
horizon initiative confirmed members are
to be arrested contained and questioned
for further information on site dr
wondertainment is a lot more amicable
with members of arwu cool yet after all
a lot of artists aren't quite able to
pay their bills on their passion
projects alone and as much as the
starving artist is a romanticized
concept these people do still really
need to eat so there are definitely
worse things as an aspiring and artist
can do than take up a part-time design
job with the fine folks at the dr
wondertainment toy company they utilize
their inherent creativity and anomaly
making skills of these desperate and
artists to create their most
delightfully devilish toys yet and
there's no shame in that after all
salvador dali did some work with disney
and designed candy logos we all have our
side gigs members and cells of are we
cool yet have also documented links to
some of the more powerful and dangerous
group of interests out there on the more
mild side of this new spectrum there's
hansarp a german daughterist and
nihilist group that was formed by
members of are we cool yet under the
instructions of the church of the broken
god-affiliated leader boris alderman we
may need to give a little extra context
here dada or dadaism to give a brief and
highly reductive definition is an early
20th century art movement formed in the
wake of the horrors of world war one
which highly disapproved of war violence
and nationalism it sought to challenge
the very boundaries of art and what
could really be considered art in the
first place so naturally it has a lot of
common philosophical ground with the
loose central ethos of the are we cool
yet movement and nihilism is in short
the belief in the lack of any inherent
meaning in life so it goes without
saying that han sarp are some pretty
intense folks but not nearly intense as
grand karcist ion or the scarlet king
and cells of are we cool yet have been
associated with both the sarcists and
the scarlet king worshippers however
their relationship with some of the
sarcists they've dealt with have been
frosty to say the least for example in
scp-2714
an anomalous copy of the adventurers of
tin tin graphic novel members of arwi
kuuya tricked a sarkist into trapping
one of his holy figures in the comic
book before killing the poor sapp's
father a lot of creators suffer for
their art but the really unpleasant
folks make other people suffer for their
art and are we cool yet has plenty of
those another are we cool yet cell known
as cool yet radio which focused on
making audio based anomalous art pieces
created
scp-4150 a version of the classic
beatles song penny lane with a
cognito-hazardous effect added
intriguingly this song contains a lyric
referencing the seventh king which is
believed to be a nod to you guessed it
the ever unpleasant nightmarish chaos
god the scarlet king there are truly all
kinds of members of are we cool yet
covering an extremely wide spectrum of
beliefs but i think we've heard more
than enough about the artists for now
how about instead we have our own little
song new devenu magnifique exhibition
right here and take a look at some of
are we cool yet's finest pieces of
anomalous art of course the
non-anomalous world is no stranger to
dangerous and provocative art pieces
performance artist marina abramovic put
herself in real danger by involving
knives and guns in her performance piece
rhythm zero and ron athey put himself at
the mercy of a wig full of needles to
raise awareness of hiv in his piece
self-obliteration but no non-anomalous
art piece will ever be as deadly as
scp-173
that's right the sculpture is heavily
theorized to be a piece of deadly anart
created by a powerful an artist known as
the sculptor it's believed to be a
commentary on the nature of humanity
itself an attention seeker who only
knows how to commit violence and
defecate for something a little less
deadly there's scp-092
a collection of 3125 cds each titled the
absolute absolute absolute absolute best
of the fifth dimension this piece was
created collaboratively by the musical
group fifth dimension and a member of
our week cool yet anyone listening to
the album is forced to listen to every
song in a row at which point anyone who
listened will exclaim wow that was real
cool however the artists felt this
wasn't their finest work and turned
themself and the cds into the scp
foundation for voluntary containment
then there's the commission piece
scp-2635
the hot potato this was initially paid
for by a chechnyan rebel group planning
to take out the russian enemies and the
an artist taking the commission was
happy to give it a theatrical and
artistic flair any group that possesses
the potato for more than one calendar
year will lose half of its members as
they begin to spontaneously combust to
keep these effects from occurring it's
continually passed between groups living
up to its nickname as the hot potato
some great art can come out of spite a
good example is
scp-4879 a soapstone polar bear statue
that has the frightening ability to take
away the special talents of anyone
standing in its proximity it was created
by an an artist filled with spite of the
success and talent of his fellow artists
and wished to take away their artistic
spark however in what seems like a
meditation on the ultimately
self-destructive nature of spite the
very creation of scp-4879
up forever squashing whatever creative
abilities its creator had then we have
this little anomalous art taster plate
the nightmare inducing scp-1057
a kind of anti-shadow a selectively
tangible shape that despite technically
not being there can behave and kill like
an adult tiger shark and to make things
even more frightening this beast was
first found after it devoured people in
an otherwise normal swimming pool a note
left by the anti-shark's creator on the
swimming pool's bulletin board red panic
means that the idea of a shark can be
more dangerous than an actual shark it
can be even more dangerous than no shark
at all are we cool yet and we're sure
that means
something there you have it folks our
crash course on the scp foundation's
most artistic enemy the are we cool yet
collective and look we're not saying
that the chaos insurgency are nice
people but they at least just have the
decency to not tell us we don't like
their murderous sight raids because we
just don't get it man now go check out
scp-001 or borrow cycle the full story
compilation and scp foundation boss the
administrator explained for more from
the weird wild world of the scp
foundation